so you know Congress has been on this
five-week vacation that they take
through all of august in the first week
of September we talked about it a couple
weeks ago this was originally set up
because they didn't have air
conditioning in the buildings in DC so
it was very hot and it gave them a
chance to go home and talk to the people
and really mix it up and do town hall
meetings and catch up on summer reading
that's actually on Congress's website as
one of the things that they do don't
baby they can't read yeah right so good
yeah right so as we speak right now
they're actually still on vacation so
even though this is all going on with
Congress right now Obama norvelt Boehner
Boehner I can't boner boner I'm calling
a boner for now they haven't called them
back officially even though this whole
war things going down but what I found
fascinating about this is that the
Democratic and Republican leaders they
actually hand out toolkits to the
members of Congress to go home that
instruct them on how to behave when they
go home and have to deal with their
constituents there now focusing on small
gatherings because remember a couple
years ago with Obamacare that these
talent the town halls got out of control
they were being yelled at and had to
answer questions and that's not what
they're in business for that they should
do more on Facebook and Twitter and
things like that what does it say about
our political system that the leaders of
the parties have to get out instructions
to Congress to go home to their
constituents that they can't just do it
on they can't even spend five weeks at
home with their own people and know how
to act they need toolkits scary I need a
how to guide gotta talk to these people
they want to talk to me and interact
with me it's terrifying and they put
they they are terrifying as evidenced by
2009 yeah and all but do you get you
have to get your job talk to the humans
yeah is there anything more terrifying
than an 80 year old woman yelling at you
about in front of a group of people and
you know no actually no yeah I I you
know I I'm not gonna jump on Congress
for this as much if I'm gonna do it
equally because those people in the who
went to those hearings are batshit crazy
and like like there's a different world
out there now
and it's true of it's what my
overwhelming sympathy for Obama is my
frustration with him outweighs my
sympathy with that for him but he's got
a party in there and we get so wrapped
up sometimes in what he's doing and or
lack of nobodies not doing but he's got
a party there that is impossible to deal
with they're not and then there then
those guys go home and you realize
partly why they're not is they just get
screamed at for stuff that they can you
know get challenges birth certificate
challenge this challenge the defund you
keep defund Obamacare got past right uh
uh uh so I don't know I wouldn't want to
go home for five weeks and sit through
those they're pointless there a giant
waste of time there for show to so look
here I am mixing with people but you're
not go to diners everyday you want to
talk to voters figure out some other way
in your district to to you know go on
give you know go to the assembly line
and talk to guys as they're working on
their lunch break but these are for show
and they ended up having vitriolic angry
sometimes racist screaming at them in
some ways I felt moderately sympathetic
some of those right well yeah I mean I
totally agree especially when it was
happening a couple years ago cuz Obama
it was crazy and it was racist and
you're right it's just a lot of people
yelling and then of course cuz the new
cycle one crazy thing gets picked up in
someone's making fun of McCain yes
essays I okay fine um but don't you
think now with exactly what's happening
right now they are home still shouldn't
they be doing this in answering
questions about the war I mean she is
that you still think no matter what it's
just show they should be explaining
themselves i mean you know look we live
at the you know we campaign in the
television age they can reach their
viewers they can reach their voters
looking twitter it's in the kit right at
12 you know maybe the kids it don't the
kids embarrassed right but we know but
of course these guys need it I mean some
of these guys are not there they're
Superdome yeah I mean you know we know I
think I'll i think most of Congress is
pretty bright I think a lot of them i
don't even know I used to think most a
lot of them are in it for the right
reasons but a lot of them were you can
see by talking to the just dumb they
don't have a sophisticated worldview
they don't think things through so they
need a kit so they need the kid can we
take away the vacation do you think that
they deserve who else gets a five-week
vacation
now there's air-conditioning now I into
later they have it and if you if you're
going to make it about then it's not
vacation it's about reconnecting with
the people than you do you have to get
over it and try to reconnect with the
people and you have to move it what do
we now never going to do it because we
got scared a couple years ago and it was
carrying uncomfortable scary and
uncomfortable I would love to see Morris
all right we're doing that again one
more time I'm so it it needs to be and I
would just love to see them maybe they
need a tool kit on how to deal with
crazy people in a strong effective way
where it is shut down because I feel
like so many of them when birthers are
these people would come at them would
get uncomfortable and not want to say no
that's insane he's not a citizen of
Kenya he does have a and and wouldn't
shut it down appropriately and so it
kept I don't know my crazy oh ah wait
listen so is the real problem here that
because of the way the system works that
we can't really get good people to
become politicians anymore so then you
get these sort of dullards especially in
Congress and then they don't want to
talk to their people cuz they really
don't know the issues i would venture to
say that there's some crazy percentage
of of congressmen that don't even
understand the basic functions of the
branches of government or or or the
names of simple foreign leaders what a
government agencies do and they're made
a government agency would it require
clothes that you know and then and then
you know and alec meets every whenever
the hell they meet and they tell
everybody in every legislature had act
and those guys every one of those guys's
you know eventually that's who makes up
the republican congress and i might you
this is no great celebration of many
Democrats either but yeah you know and
obviously old when you get back to it
with that all it all comes down to
getting money out of politics and
because the real issue isn't whether
they take five weeks off to go home
which is the idea in the first place I
mean that's really why it's there's this
wouldn't be a Congress that was there 50
weeks a year in session in Washington
the real issue is that the the health
care bill was written by insurance
companies and and that every other bill
that we have is Rena and the banking
business and the what Wall Street wrote
the banking reform law that those are
the that's what that's why these guys
don't understand they don't have to
understand it they get they have
corporate interests writing
laws that now govern the rest of the
other memories progresses turning
against Obama it's just something so
largely sympathetic to exact as i said i
don't know what I'm supposed to do with
these guys I literally don't know what
he's supposed to do he's been
unsuccessful I got that but I don't know
what he's gonna do and that's the irony
of the situation why I started that the
idea that he's now going to approve a
war from a group that is fifteen percent
approval only in America would that make
sense even though that's what he should
do